WAYNE PIEKARSKI: Hi.
My name's Wayne
Piekarski, and I work
as a developer
advocate at Google.
Today I'm going to talk
about Android Wear,
and how you can take
advantage of adding pages
to your existing notifications.
If you're just getting
started, you first
might want to view some
of our previous DevBytes.
You'll also want to get set up
with the Android Wear developer
preview, and get it
working on your machine.
So let's write an Android
Wear application that
helps keep track
of library books
that I'm borrowing
for my next adventure.
So the app will
generate notifications
whenever books
you've borrowed are
overdue to be returned
to the library.
On a phone, there'll be
a single notification
indicating how many
books are overdue.
So with an Android
Wear device, this
is easily glanceable
on your wrist,
and you can see the notification
without pulling your phone out
of your pocket.
Now since wearable
displays are quite small,
there's a limit to what you
can see in a single glance,
however.
So what can we do about this?
With Android Wear, we
support adding extra pages
to a notification, allowing
you to swipe sideways,
and see a lot more information.
On the wearable, we can see
the specific titles and authors
of each book that are
overdue, and there
can be some kind of action
at the end, as well.
So how do we go and
implement all of this?
For a phone
application, your code
will currently be traversing
some kind of array or list
of books within
a loop like this,
and then calculating how
many are overdue from it.
You're probably
already doing this
to generate the main
notification you can see here
on the phone screenshot
at the bottom, there.
To add extra pages, what you
do is you modify your code
to keep a list of
extra notifications.
So here, I've created
an array list,
which we will use to
store these for use later.
You would now modify your loop
to generate a new notification
for each overdue item,
with whatever text
you want inside of it,
like this code, here.
And you should add each of
these into your array list
for use later on.
So adding the extra
pages to your code
is now really, really easy.
So this is what your existing
code might look like right now.
And then we now make a code
to a method called addPages.
And this takes in a
collection, so you can just
pass in the extras list
you created earlier
as a single argument.
So here, you can see it's
just a one line change.
So make sure you also use the
new NotificationManagerCompat
instead of the
NotificationManager
from the framework so that
the new notifications will
work properly with
wearable devices.
And finally, you
can combine pages
with a stack feature
that was discussed
in my previous
DevByte. [? bite. ?]
So there are lots of
combinations that are possible
here, based on whatever
you want to do.
So that's it for pages.
It's a really, very simple way
of adding extra functionality
to your existing
Android applications.
And you can find out more about
Android Wear and the developer
preview by visiting
our website here.
And also, I want you to go
and join our Google+ community
and share what other great
ideas you have for Android Wear
as well.
So I'm Wayne Piekarski,
and I'll see you next time.